what did we feed you that's making you
fart like this oh I'm sorry it mean to
hurt your feelings but it's true I know
being Game of Thrones isn't real even
though we all wish it was
oh hello is this is this hangout time we
we haven't a chance
you don't want to sleep in your bed what
this isn't good enough for you can you
shut the door this is what you wanted to
be yeah this is what you it's what you
like you think you'd hump yourself if
you could you ever think about how
you're not wearing any clothes wearing a
collar is like the only clothing you
have okay get more action than I am I'm
sorry that's rude when you get excited
everyone can see it at least I have
pants on what are you thank you for
protecting the house being Rimmer came
in here we all we did okay you're gonna
be a party animal let me do you party
putting me up no I don't like cats
either fine you are not a guard dog
right Hey you're not scary enough can we
just find a place to sit and sit there
I'm sorry I took away your balls not oh
okay it kind of rush I'm afraid of
thunder - your haircuts cost more than
mine - oh that's not right beam did you
fart oh god gross puppy think it's scary
life is scary
getting your not gross unite euros your
adore oh god you are actually quite
quite smelly getting some getting action
huh all the petals good cuddler
you're good cuddler beam